I'm curious because you're a bit older  so what like what I'm just curious what  are you you're familiar with red pill it  seems like do you see that that older  women get past how do I put it they the  guys they rejected earlier will turn  them down later yes it happens a lot it  happens because you see the women and  they think oh no I remember there was a  man and he was  um he didn't look younger I didn't look  all that nobody was after him he became  a Dustbin man you know nobody was after  him and they got old and he got more  handsome and he got a nice kind of thing  everybody's after him you know why  because they realize how much dust men  wanted how much they earn and then when  they were after him he didn't want them  he got some girl you know he was a  dustman I think he married like a lawyer  or something like that okay because she  saw his worth and it wasn't how much he  earned it was a good guy with potential  but nobody wanted nobody